three seconds to go Arkansas by two
expected to miss here
oh he tried to miss it off the bank
Arkansas gets it in they get it to block
the club ticks
and the Razorbacks
survive in advance
to the Sweet 16. Arkansas
wins it and they knock off the defending
national champions
[Applause]
Brian the Kansas coaching staff called
this a toughness game
you throw X's and O's out at some point
this Razorback team stepped up big time
oh yeah you deserve to take your shirt
off hey you deserve to take because they
could have easily folded in when Kansas
made their run in the second half but
the lineup
that was led by Devoe Davis the little
things
allowed him to get back into